sag uns wer ist denn noch alles dabei
und vor allem wer ist die größte
überraschung dieses jahr
hallo liebe ja wir müssen unterscheiden
wir haben sechs kandidaten die bisher
unbekannt waren das ist einmal die
claudia kohde kilsch ex-tennisprofi und
politikerin
casey kelly von der kelly family china
güler vor blogs schauspieler die lehne
lucia meur von berlin tag & nacht ein
virus die wir vor allem das blut
internet kennen und mischa meyer den
bodybuilder
dazu haben wir dann acht kandidaten die
bild bereits berichtet hatte und die
jetzt von dort einst auch offiziell
bestätigt wurden jasmin tawil sascha
heyna das kbk der us major otto ernst
rupp und ikke hüftgold sowie die beiden
die noch live in der show einziehen
werden das ist einmal simone ballack die
ex von michael ballack und co
die hat dort einst noch nicht bestätigt
aber bild weiß dass sie live einziehen
werden herr icke hüftgold hatte erst
dementiert dass er dabei ist jetzt also
doch wissen wir warum es da sein hin und
her gab
ja das hat nicht nur uns alle überrascht
die wir hier ich habe ja schon mal rüber
berichtet für bild und dann kamen das
dementi von herrn hüftgold er dachte
natürlich vorher nicht drüber sprechen
aber dass er dementiert war überraschend
aber wie gesagt hat nicht nur uns
überrascht sondern auch sat 1 und die
produktionsfirma weil die wussten dass
er dabei sein wird er hat das dann
intern so erklärt das gehöre zu seiner
kunstfigur solche aktionen
denn jetzt steht er ja dazu dass er
teilnimmt und wir wissen aber auch zu
dem zeitpunkt also dementiert hat hat er
den freitag schon unterschrieben also
eine sehr komische aktion die andere
ehrlich gesagt vor allem ihn
unglaubwürdig macht mal sehen also wer
sich dann im tv knast schlägt kurze
einschätzung von dir werd die größten
chancen an deinen augen
ja man muss natürlich ein bisschen
abwarten wie das im haus und container
dass er dieses jahr eine burg sein wird
selbst laufen wird aber erfahrungsgemäß
haben immer die grössten chancen die
diese sogenannte heldenreise hinlegen
also die im laufe der show eine
entwicklung durchmachen
das traurig so eine elena mehr zu die
ich schon eine weile kennedy
potenzial oder auch otto benz trotz der
sehr frech ist der dass so eine
entwicklung auch durchgehen könnte wenn
er auf die leute selbst trifft aber auch
casey kelly die schon seit jahren kenne
ist eine echte sympathieträgerin die
könnte so eine rolle im container
spielen wie damals silvia wollen die so
als mama der kompanie